these two women and their families have
lost virtually everything a few months
ago their husbands were well-paid
well-respected military officers
representing turkey at NATO headquarters
in Brussels now they're in hiding from
that government accused of being
terrorists we have to disguise their
identities because they fear retaliation
we've even told our children not to
speak Turkish in public anymore a couple
months after the failed military coup
they were ordered to return to Turkey
accused of having links to those who
tried to overthrow president red-tipped
I aperto one at first we wanted to go
back to Turkey I wanted to defend myself
but there's no case to defend myself
against and then we learned that the
people who did go back or jailed we meet
them and others caught up in the purge
at an apartment near NATO one of them is
a high ranking military officer accused
of helping to plan the coup from his
NATO post he tells us he had nothing to
do with it they tweaked the legislative
system in Turkey and invented new crimes
to be able to discharge people from
their offices to imprison people even to
torture people in their custody or in
prison asked for reaction to these cases
many think tanks and NGOs are reluctant
to criticize the Turkish government in
public worried for their own personnel
there only Amnesty International's
Andrew Gardner in Istanbul was willing
to talk it was test me from lawyers
who've actually met with people in
detention and daughters as well and
unfortunately they gave a very
disturbing picture of ill-treatment and
torture insides police detention in
Turkey era de juan has declared that
diplomats posted abroad whose names are
on his list must return home or he'll
hunt them down and bring them back
forcefully that's exactly what the
families in Brussels now fear we have
nothing now
no state no Passport you think it's just
a pause not an end we've applied for
asylum we'll start over but turkey has
already warned NATO member states
including Belgium they must send these
officers back when we asked nato
secretary general Yin's stoltenberg
about the situation he defends turkeys
utility as a partner Turk is important
for the migrant and refugee crisis and a
buffer for the rest of Europe the women
say they are afraid their asylum request
will be rejected if so they'll try to go
somewhere else it's a big world with a
lot of countries there must be one that
will take us meanwhile the women are
constantly learning of new cases just
like there's families forced into hiding
wondering if the lists will ever end